and this is interesting i'm kind of
excited for this year's i was excited
for this year's one I didn't do a lot of
research on it out same here I didn't
want to you know I just want to kind of
approach it with right fresh shut eyes
and yeah just get into it but I did look
at least at the history of the wood it
was based on just so I knew where it was
coming from didn't read much about what
happened in the medieval stories but
what's cool is it this isn't really
based off a novel or some big new why a
book or some book like Game of Thrones
that like millions of people of red I
mean people have read it but it is based
off of these 19th century but they used
to call him serials like David
Copperfield and things like that that
release little chunks a little mystery
here little mystery there and produce
some very interesting characters you
might know you know Sweeney Todd yeah
The Barber of Seville that's a character
from this story at the Ripper yeah
that's a river is mentioned in this
again we're gonna spoil so I mean what
if you haven't seen it you know go on
showtime calm go on the YouTube page
watch the episode it's free don't pay
anything for it so go ahead and watch it
now and come back and watch this review
and its really interesting it's kind of
like a goon squad like Ghostbusters are
like supernatural shola and often fight
these monsters let me just go through
the main cast real quick just to make
sure we got Timothy Dalton yes mr. James
Bond himself we got Eva Green as Vanessa
Ives I'm sorry Timothy Dalton to play
sir malcolm we have josh hartnett his
back the heartthrob himself in a while
been a while since the days of his uh
you know chick flick movies but he is
back uh looks pretty good looks the same
actually this young guy named a harry
treadaway who plays dr. Victor
Frankenstein which is the big reveal at
the end you don't know his name so I
guess we'll go into detail but like just
started for first you know first
impressions were your first impressions
of the show well can't like we said
earlier and stuff I just kind of wanted
to approach it I kind of got a little
idea of what it would be around so but I
just wanted to enjoy it for what it was
worth and I was really impressed I
really enjoyed it like you said it did
kind of like I thought it shows like
supernatural and just things like that
yeah kind of you can tell that they want
to have fun with this but it's not it's
not corn it's not over the top or
anything like that I thought all the
performances are really well done hon I
was impressed with her tonight yeah he
really held his own personally I really
loved eva green in this episode I
thought a her character has a lot to
offer you don't know too much about it
in the episode
art software this little girls in bed
and I'm assuming that your character
yeah i'm assuming and I'm soon that's
her mother that goes into like a Russian
whatnot gets abducted by who be careful
to use a restroom with middle and I here
be careful know what's lurking but as
I'm assuming that's there so like it we
see like you know their their moments
when she's praying from the cross and
stuff and she's just like I feel that
she owns every scene that she's in at
least in this episode so far again I
feel like of all the characters she has
the most to offer but everyone you know
really held their own and this guy
played a victor frankenstein like I'd we
didn't know until the very end on him he
was but he was really impressive who's
good his characters good his acting was
just like on par with everyone else
which is a good thing and I like a nerd
jump to the interlude but I love the the
Frankenstein reveal cuz went over the
you know Frank assign you know the book
isn't really you know gory and horror I
mean it's it's got its graphic but it's
not like you know raw I mean he's like a
really intended that Frankenstein moment
like they set it up is gonna be really
scary yeah that was really intimate like
holders of the Fate okay quiet it wasn't
leading up to that it was a little clean
oh yeah a cup like you kept going down
and everything gets dark and the light
to come back and he's gone but no you're
absolutely right that was really well
done um and then like again we get
mentions of Jack the Ripper's yeah and
then there's and also they're vampires
so but like that they don't call them
that they don't know like the hell the
creature yeah or a preacher like hey do
you have a creature like this which is
cool and the way it's shot is great this
was interesting i didn't do research
just on the creators so John Logan wrote
this and he's going to write what looks
like an intv at least all of the
episodes I'm gonna be a John Logan wrote
the screenplay for Skyfall and you have
saya Mendez who is executive producers
they basically had the whole Skyfall
team and you have Timothy Dalton who was
this guy well but you have a former
James Bond for the way we were curious
John Logan also wrote gladiator he also
wrote sweetie Todd with Johnny Depp and
of course you of the musical so I mean
there's all it's it's really good all
your the eight episodes I'm Showtime you
know HBO Showtime there were new stuff
like in two days so hopefully yeah once
it premieres hopefully they were new it
instantly but I really liked this also
like the mood with its it's really dark
we watched it kind of a darker room and
it was like it was dark like
everything's dark in the show very dark
very gory absolutely so I'm here
so squeamish yeah prepare yourself right
but yeah overall like you said like the
tone just fell right for what you gonna
do that's why it's not it that's what I
thought of shows like you know like
supernatural yeah yeah but but it's not
an ambient at all no no no it's it's so
well done I thought the acting is great
shot well it's beautiful I know we're
talking about this to like shows like
Showtime show something kind of feel
like you're watching a movie and stuff
and this one definitely had that feel I
mean not just the cast which isn't
everything about it yeah great direction
look great I mean I really in a guy who
I don't really know much about even
though he's popular Timothy Dalton I
mean I know him from James by no he's
done other things been around for years
but he was really good he's a little
he's acting in this like you can say
he's acting but he doing in the good way
like this one scene that we Mike and I
both cracked up on when eva green
Vanessa Ives her character comes in and
says and Dalton says we have an
appointment and then it opens like where
we go and he's like amongst deads things
I guess darken his British into it and
he's really acting but he's doing a good
job I like the cast another character
did mention is this some Egyptian yeah
he could translate hieroglyphics he is
really over the top of cool i was just
gonna mention that too because yes the
show was dark it's a little gory but it
has fun moments as well but i can't
remember his name yeah murmurs but I
mean he was a lot of fun that's actually
a little more of a light-hearted seen
you know given like you know what
they're talking about or whatnot but he
was really good i wish you'd remembers
never his name back but he was really
funny and he was really well i hope to
see him a little bit more we also know
now granted we didn't I don't believe we
saw him in the first episode but other
characters like Dorian Gray yes so the
cool thing what the show is it's almost
like a van Helsing tale where they can
kind of throw whatever mythological
beasts or creatures or you know
mythology they wanted to throw when they
can do whatever they want basically
which is cool there's no limits because
it was based off of the serials which
rate for Mike and I reviewing here I
don't know about what Mike thinks but I
know Dennis and I we review game of
thrones and they could be a little
stressful sometimes because there's so
many fans look I read the book but I'm
not as passionate maybe it's some fancy
like or so like like this is the way it
is the way it's supposed to be worse I
doubt there's I'm sure there's some of
you out there who have read the serials
but probably fewer people that have gone
back around 19th century yeah serials on
Penny dreadful so it's a little bit nice
to come to something fresh that's a good
point pressure behind this yes
is watch it same thing with shows like
The Walking Dead and stuff compared to
like the comics in this yeah absolutely
but it's like it kind of handcuffs
itself a little bit because it's like
you don't want to veer too far off the
books then you're gonna get people fans
of the books all like you know real
crime bloody murder whatnot but that's
true it's good and the next thing is to
just one more thing I want to say I like
the monster so far they're not pretty
this is not going to be true blood I
doubt this is going to turn into a
melodrama so popper like this is not
sexy vampires I they there's vampires
look kind of weird while I had no
Twilight a little weird so I like that
we're getting back to the monsters I
think yeah FX is doing a show called the
strain that Guerin with all toros doing
that's going to be like that too so you
know hey it's the monsters are still
here it's still in still around but
those were our thoughts on the penny
dreadful premiere really liked it again
you can check it out for free right now
the first episode maybe might convince
you to subscribe to showtime maybe not
but as always you can come chat with us
at think hero.com you can also check us
out on this youtube page at think hero
pro be sure to LIKE subscribe you know
comment you know try to get get back to
those comments as soon as we can also
we're on twitter dennis michael myself
were all on at think hero i'm at griffin
de and i'm at mr. Michael Alexis we also
the facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think your fans be sure to
subscribe or sorry you know give us a
like and spread the word social media
helps us a lot and you hope you enjoy
pretty gentle
you